it's a question that we haven't gotten
an answer to for basically a decade what
exactly did Heidi do or not do was she
responsible for the rumors Lauren Conrad
had a sex tape or not
well Stephanie Pratt is going off in a
new Instagram post claiming Heidi did
start those sex tape rumors okay in this
lengthy Instagram caption Steph calls
out to her sister-in-law quote Heidi I
have no words for how evil you truly are
and for real we all know what you did
ten years ago you awful human being and
to your best friend you are truly a
hideous person no wonder you don't have
one friend your nanny doesn't count you
pay her snap Heidi left off the sex tape
rumors with me though last month you
know what you did
we are at the seat of that and I know I
never did anything but that same night
Stephanie was feeling all sorts of
emotional tonight is really
uncomfortable for me there's just so
much I mean the show is just the biggest
part of my life right now because it's
just all so real and every aspect of me
is on it so I don't know I'm scared to
see what people think when you save them
you mean Spencer Heidi
we don't say their name still no Heidi
and Spencer had a different perspective
on this what would it take for you and
Stephanie to reconcile at this point I
have no issues with anyone Steph was
definitely not feeling the love even
said that things that Spencer has done
has triggered you being hospitalized do
you know what what happened there I'm
it's a few times and
it's just I'm you know my I can't get
enjoy right now I'll be here for hours
Stephanie doesn't stop its Spidey though
she also had some words for Audrina
Patridge Audrina's best friend is
catching on to you guys having a little
fling thing what that bill like Joey
whatever her name is on Hill's new
beginnings Audrina seems to have caught
feelings for Justin Bobby again but
thinks he's actually hooking up with
Stephanie Stephanie says quote Justin
Bobby you were my rock the entire series
I love you and thank you
PS spoiler alert we never hooked up
Audrina is crazy like you dated this guy
ten years ago you married someone else
and have a child with him and as if you
like Justin you were dating someone off
camera no one plays a better victim than
you
OMG you actually should go into acting
the guys stephanie claims Audrina was
dating was the guy Ashley and Jason set
her up with a bar owner named Matt chase
I will say Audrina and Justin did make
it seem like they both had feelings when
I was with them though either still
sparked I think there's always gonna be
chemistry between us and that everyone
talks about it it's whether or not yeah
it's all about timing what kind of
journey do you guys take us on this
season we're just gonna get reconnected
and kind of getting to learn each other
a little bit more again we were kids
when we were like hanging out so now
we're a little bit more of adults I
guess you're gonna see that do we see
sparks fly between you guys there always
be some kind of spark there I mean we've
known each other for so long and gone
through so much stuff together
how could I know now if you're wondering
my Stephanie put this all out on social
media she says it's her life my life is
basically sharing all of my feelings and
my opinions publicly so I'm gonna keep
doing me alright guys what do you think
is Heidi actually responsible for
starting those rumors about LC what do
you make of what she said about
let me know and for all the latest on
the hills and so much more
keep it locked to all things ET until
next time I'm Katie Krause and bye for
now
you